I could please have everyone take their
seats we're going to be starting in just
a moment
my name is Peter own and i'm the dean of
the school of general studies i'm a
professor of Islamic religion and so i
am in total awe of your scientific
accomplishments it's something i am
incapable of and i am extraordinarily
proud to be the Dean of a school that
really Foster's this extraordinary
extraordinary program and really
extraordinary individuals and so on
behalf of the Columbia faculty and
administration I want to welcome you
this afternoon to the class day ceremony
celebrating the accomplishments of the
graduates of the post baccalaureate
pre-medical pre-health program the
oldest
the oldest and most distinguished
program of its type in the country we
gather together to recognize both the
extraordinary intellectual
accomplishments of the graduates and
their commitment to a career of
humanitarian service I am reminded that
the challenges you face today are
challenges healthcare professionals have
faced for hundreds of years one of the
great medical scientists of the early
medieval period was the Muslim physician
abubakar vazi who died in 925 he was
known in later European Latin sources as
roses a renowned practitioner and
researcher Razi worked at the center of
learning an imperial power at the time
in baghdad his greatest work the
encyclopedia of medicine was translated
into latin and published five times up
through the 16th century now I don't
know what that says about 16th century
medicine that they were still using in
early 10th century text but he was
clearly a renowned scholar of medicine
throughout the Western world but towards
the end of his life for Ozzy was under
attack from the religious conservatives
of his time for privileged enris in' and
the quest for scientific knowledge over
religious dogma in one of his last
writings before his death the attempt to
defend the role of science and healing
in a world plagued by dogmatism he
argues that socrates life should be the
model for the muslim scientist after
death he writes
we shall find ourselves in a state that
is either admirable or reprehensible
according to the life we have lived
while our souls were associated with our
bodies the Supreme end for which we were
created and towards which we have been
led is not the gratification of physical
pleasures but the acquisition of
knowledge and the practice of justice
these two occupations the quest for
are our sole deliverance out of the
present world into the world wherein is
neither pain nor death I can think of no
individuals Oh better embody these
ideals of knowledge and justice than
those of you sitting before us today you
are scientists but also humans artists
social scientists all dedicated to the
pursuit of truth and the alleviation of
suffering and like grazi over a thousand
years ago you will face scientific and
ethical challenges even condemnation
that would overwhelm most people I am
convinced however that once you enter
upon your careers as healthcare
professionals you will be fully equipped
to engage and grapple with these
challenges on behalf of all of us at
Columbia I want you to know how proud we
are of your accomplishments how proud we
are to count you members of the Columbia
family I would like to introduce to you
Dean Victoria rosner Dean rosner will
introduce today's keynote speaker
Thank You Dean on and welcome once again
to all of you thank you so much for
joining us here today on this extremely
important occasion it's my pleasure to
introduce to you our keynote speaker dr.
Stephen Nicholas dr. Nicholas is already
well known to many of you as the dean of
admissions for the Columbia University
School of Physicians and Surgeons but he
is also a pediatrician who was at the
forefront of developing treatment for
the first generations of children born
infected with the HIV virus he has cared
for these children in Harlem in
Washington Heights and in the Dominican
Republic during his time as director of
pediatrics at Harlem Hospital he also
founded the Harlem Children's Zone
asthma initiative in 1999 dr. Nicholas
founded the Columbia University
international family aids program which
introduced the first aids treatment for
pregnant women and long term aids care
and treatment for families in Dominican
Republic thanks largely to dr.
Nicholas's work the city of La Romana in
the Dominican Republic has lowered the
rate of mother-to-child HIV transmission
to a rate comparable with New York's dr.
Nicholas is tremendous commitment to
both local and international Public
Health has been honored with many awards
including the Clare Lucille pace
Humanitarian Award from Columbia
University and the New York State
Governor's Award for outstanding service
on behalf of children with AIDS he is
the founder and director of the Columbia
University international family aids
program providing health services
education and research in the Dominican
Republic johannesburg haiti and st.
Petersburg I knew very little about dr.
Nicholas's extraordinary public health
record when I first met him I mostly
knew that he had recently been named
associate dean of admissions for
Columbia
and I suggested that we go out to lunch
then and since I have been struck
repeatedly by his erudition his kindness
his care his modesty and his immense
dedication to students my opinion of him
could scarcely be higher but most of the
students actually think he has magical
powers since he appears to hold the
total contents of each of their
admissions files in his head and will
pick them out information session since
aid don't you play the jazz tuba or
aren't you fond of chihuahuas and they
just go along I think the truth is
actually more impressive than magic he
cares deeply about making each of the
students feel important and valued it
has been a privilege to know and work
with him and I could not be more
delighted that he is here to speak with
us today ladies and gentlemen dr. Steve
Nicholas
boy I don't know if I can live up to
that introduction or not being on being
roster mellow Dean's faculty members
parents friends graduates it really is
an honor to be here with you this
afternoon you know a year ago I didn't
really know very much about the Columbia
postback pre-med program it had a good
reputation great reputation I had
interviewed over the years of being on
the admissions committee several
individuals that had come out of this
program and I can remember that they
stuck out of my mind as being unusually
interesting little older than average
culturally broad background circuitous
paths to medicine but possessing I
thought a kind of hybrid vigor but these
are sort of vague impressions but over
the past year I've gotten to know the
program's leadership some of the faculty
many of the students here primarily
because of that lunch you just heard
about maybe the first day of my new
position as as dean for admissions and
Victoria rosner quickly realized that I
wasn't quite dry behind the ears so at
this lunch she tried to keep her jaw
from dropping when I asked what's a
glide year and I confessed that I didn't
know what linkage was all about and so
the rest is history I can tell you that
it's with great enthusiasm that we've
accepted our first 11 linkage students
for the incoming class of 2015 and what
a stellar group they are
so I feel very much like I'm here today
with a large group of friends or friends
to be and it's truly an honor to be here
with all of you well when I started
speaking years ago a friend of mine took
me aside and said let me just sort of
give you the rules he said if you're
going to be seeing stand up if you're
going to be heard speak up if you're
going to be appreciated shut up so my
comments will be brief the same friend
also advised me when you going to give a
talk always finish writing your speech
at least a week in advance throw it in
the corner leave it alone come back to
it a couple days before you speak
rehearse it a couple times then get a
good night's sleep the night before get
up do some exercises have a light
breakfast dress stiffly skip the morning
news read a fun novel and then you'll be
mentally and physically prepared as you
can be so using all that advice I did
those things and I woke this morning did
my exercise ate my breakfast hopped on
the train from Northern Westchester with
my finished talk in my briefcase and
proceeded to read Steve Martin's new
novel an object of beauty which is about
the New York art scene turns out to be
very good reading and then I started to
hear the most disturbing conversation
which I'll tell you about in a moment so
that was the beginning of my morning was
so disturbed after I got off the truth
the train I then went into an event over
at Columbia that turned out to be one of
the most exhilarating events that I
in recent time and then I went back to
my office I threw my talk away and I
rewrote my talk so you're going to have
to tell me whether that was a big
mistake or not let me first of all say a
word to the parents and to the end of
the teachers to some degree but
especially the parents we're here to
graduate a whole group of marvelous
individuals and to celebrate that
graduation but I'm also a father of four
children ages 15 to 21 I'm a
pediatrician professor so I really am
here to celebrate both the parents and
the teachers we've got a corporate
responsibility to remember the past
celebrate celebrate the present and hope
for the future of each graduate now
perched on the launch of a medical
education and career so on days like
today I I can always feel myself getting
just pull back into the nostalgic
remembering that wonder filled day of
birth when out came the head and then
one shoulder and then the other children
and the whole little body and the
umbilical clamp goes on and you're
waiting with bated breath for the Apgar
scores and the first ones usually eight
and the second ones usually nine and
you're thinking come on my kid deserves
a tan
so you start having these sort of
thoughts now on the one hand you start
letting your mind race if not then in
the delivery room very soon and and then
for years you you race to the future you
you wonder big longitudinal thoughts
like will my child grow up to be
successful will he be good will she be
happy now the father in pediatrician and
me know that along the way there are
some less elegant real life thoughts
fueled by peers of frustration or just
fears and and the everyday work load of
childbearing and some of us had thoughts
like these will this kid ever ever ever
sleep through the night and our fears
were playing by the story of the college
freshman who had never once in 18 years
left through the night who by the way
did not go to Harvard I don't want to
start any false rumors and i was asked
more than once is it true that the
American Academy of Pediatrics no longer
sanctions the use of sleep inducing
sugar cubes soaked with Jen and some of
us suppressed thoughts like should I do
something now or wait till my child
walks to approach the Olympic soccer
coach or my wife's real question after
our purse born came along am I really
expected to breastfeed after his teeth
come in so like raising children is
filled with innumerable small concerns
but on days like today we return to big
longitudinal thoughts when today feels
like an end point at which we can say
something about whether the graduates
before us have turned out to be
successful happy or good we can say
congratulations for your success and
graduating from the oldest the largest
and in arguably one of the very best and
most wonderfully preparatory postback
pre-med program
the country but we also know that today
is not really an end point but simply a
landmark and a path to something more
real more important because what really
concerns each of you graduates is the
future what lies ahead what is my life
as a doctor going to be like and during
this raucous and polarized period of
debate over health care reform all of
you undoubtedly have heard some negative
even alarming things so let me tell you
about the conversation on the train
there I am reading my nice little book
not bother in a soul when I overheard
two individuals who turned out to be
pre-med students working part-time for
doctors and private practice and
apparently so I ever heard they've taken
their mcats you're going to be applying
to medical schools next year and for the
first half of the trip they incessantly
complained about how horrible medicine
had become how outside interference in
medicine had stolen doctors power the
people there are people with far less
knowledge that have been the position
who are making all the decisions the
patient's no longer trust doctors that
you used to be able to make a decent
living but now medicine just doesn't pay
and then they proceeded to talk about
ways that they dreamed to maximize their
income while minimizing their hours
including opening up more labs buying
more imaging machines and then they
talked in the most arisa Tway imaginable
about the problem patients they
encounter they didn't talk about names
but they were just completely irreverent
and I was quite upset in hearing this
and I wanted to say something but it was
held my tongue getting off the train
with what Edith Wharton called the
belated eloquence of
inarticulate my head been filling with
really clever but way too late one
liners
well on my way to the Medical Center
this morning I began to wonder if we in
academic institutions are excessively
sheltered from some of the realities
that confront the field of medicine
especially private practitioners those
two students might have been mimicking
what they hear on the on the job from
the doctors they work with we all hear
stories about doctors who become soured
on medicine and perhaps the problem is
more pervasive than I think perhaps my
own personal vantage point is narrow
non-representative I've had 30 years of
an endlessly fascinating career working
with children with HIV and their
families that you've heard in Harlem
Washington Heights Dominican Republic
and I got to tell you my idealism burns
probably brighter than it did when I was
first in medical school and my own
enthusiasm for medicine is absolutely
undiminished and I know the same could
be said for colleagues that I've worked
with for years but perhaps were
anomalies a cloud of doubt began to
creep over my consciousness so I knew I
was headed to give this this talk this
afternoon and I wondered if my remarks
which which I wanted to be optimistic
and encouraging would somehow be
unrealistically off the mark would I be
leading all of you down some sort of a
garden path well with those sort of
clouds lingering over me I then went to
the pns alumni day in which i
participated in the 50th anniversary of
the class of nineteen sixty one in which
a group of academics researchers
significant number of people in private
practice reenacted their grand
uation from medical school each graduate
from the class came forward received a
diploma Roy baggia Lohse and graduated
from P and s in 1953 that that was the
year of my birth folks that was a long
time ago former CEO of Merck who
recently donated 50 million dollars to
Columbia to build a new medical
education building talked absolutely in
a riveting enthusiastic weyba about the
work he's still doing in drug
development and medical education he
then read the Hippocratic oath in Greek
and then the entire group of doctors not
just the class of six do you wanted
everyone present assembled and proceeded
to read the modern English version the
Hippocratic note that we use for every
incoming group of medical students
during the white coat ceremony at which
we then use again at the time of
graduation and I want to read it to you
now those of you who are coming into
medicine are going to hear this again
but it seems to me during these times
when we have self doubts and we wonder
where medicine is headed it is not a bad
idea simply to hear the words of this oh
I swear to fulfill to the best of my
ability and judgment this covenant I
will respect the hard-won scientific
gains of those positions in whose step I
walk and gladly share such knowledge as
is mine with those who are to follow I
will apply for the benefit of the sick
all measures that are required avoiding
those twin traps of over treatment and
therapeutic nihilism I will remember
that there is art to medicine as well as
science and that warmth sympathy and
understanding may outweigh the surgeon's
knife or the chem
strug I will not be ashamed to say I
know not nor will I fail to call in my
colleagues when the skills of another
are needed for a patient's recovery I
will respect the privacy of my patients
for their problems are not disclosed to
me that the world may know most
especially must I tread with care and
matters of life and death it is given to
me to save it my all thanks but it may
also be within my power to take a life
this awesome responsibility must be
faced with great humbleness and
awareness of my own frailty above all I
must not play at God I will remember
that I do not treat a fever chart a
cancerous growth but a sick human being
whose illness may affect the person's
family and economic stability my
responsibility includes these related
problems if i am to care adequately for
the sick i will prevent disease whenever
i can for prevention is preferable to
cure i will remember that I remain a
member of society with special
obligations to all my fellow human
beings those sound of mind and body as
well as the infirm if I do not violate
this oath may I enjoy life and art
respected while I live and remembered
with affection thereafter may I always
act so as to preserve the finest
traditions of my calling and may had
long experience the joy of healing those
who seek my help there wasn't a dry eye
in the group so this is more than
nostalgia this is what everybody signed
on up for so in the class of nineteen
sixty one fifty years ago and is still a
set of moral standards to which they
still adhere so it was more like really
a golden wedding anniversary celebrating
this love affair between two people who
have deeply respected each other for 50
years the talk before and after this
event was about the profound admiration
these doctors
have had and continue to have for the
profession of Medicine privilege was the
word I heard repeatedly I was privileged
to become a doctor they weren't
complaining about the sacrifices they've
made they weren't saying in which
they've made more money they reveled in
the disbelief as one person put it that
many are called and fewer chosen
repeatedly I heard the word calling
although many of them are now retired a
surprising number still involved in
patient care researcher teaching what I
didn't hear what's was you know this
profession has gone to the dogs or I
really wish I gone into investment
banking or HMOs have ruined everything
or I wished I'd retired sooner though in
fairness it's certainly possible that
any graduate from the class of 61 who
feels that way might have chosen to stay
home who knows but but this was not a
group which anyone assumed the tone of a
or for those of you who read Winnie the
Pooh you know that gloomy moping a
donkey who who famously said well it's
not much of a tale but I'm kind of
attached to it
no this was a group that let's see where
that's losing my place to have really
bright very enthusiastic stimulating
people the concept I've heard expressed
most this morning was about renewal the
secret to being a good doctor for many
years said one was the art of regular
self renewal one of them said this
morning that while he didn't love all
the constraints and complexities and
battles with health insurance companies
that came along with managed care he
still felt that health care reform was
critically important we have to find a
more affordable way to take care of all
of us he said we can't go back to a
system for the rich that deprives the
four he then said if you're going to
stay on the top of the tide of change
called progress you can't sit still I
get amused he said when colleagues
complain that medicine is changing I
tell them of course it's changing well
it is true medicine has changed
constantly from the time of Hippocrates
I love to point to people point people
to my favorite new yorker cartoon which
shows Adam and Eve rushing out of the
Garden of Eden clutching their big leads
to themselves and Adam turns to Eve and
says I think we're in a period of
transition
well we are in a period of transition
but certain things won't change the core
value at the center of Medicine this
wonderful agreement that patients have
with the doctors that allows us the
doctors to listen with the compassionate
ear to utmost secrets that allows us to
touch exam and even invade their bodies
in the hopes of improving their element
that is very sacred sankt timeless and
that's a relationship that will never
change if doctors get up every morning
and the first thing they think about is
the quality of life of their patients
then they have come into medicine for
the right reasons and those reasons will
withstand changes in the landscape so
never mind those two on the train we're
not going to accept him anyway night
hope
I really I really hope they find their
just rewards doing something that
doesn't require them to catch a human
being so remember the class of 61 there
are role models that's who I want to be
when I grow up they can attest in
moments when we waver that there is no
higher calling the medicine that the
future shines brightly for all of us who
carry on in pursuit of the high ideals
that have brought us this farm thank
thank you dr. Nicholas your inspiring
words as I look out on the crowd of
students who are completing the
requirements for the postback
certificate I see so much potential and
I'm struck by what a short time you've
all been here from your first physics
again exam through last night's biology
final many of you would agree that it
seems like only months but in that time
you've grown intellectually and socially
and you've matured and thought indeed
just as your family and friends sharing
the pride of your hard-earned
accomplishments so does everyone at
Columbia University who's tried to help
you realize your dreams while you've
been here I'm now happy to say that the
time has come to recognize you
individually I now invite beans on and
rosner Dean sunshine and Dean Mitchell
Janet Griffith from the alumni affairs
office and professors mouth shoe it's in
Hazen to step forward and help us
congratulate our nose graduates when
your name is called please step to the
days Mercedes all bruh
Robert L
me up and we
mark father
John Barnes
Kristen Beck
Rebecca Bernstein
Kate fiblets
all files
Alexandra blaze
joseph Blanco
leave Sam Bosco
Aaron Robert
Jason Burmeister
Michael certo
Linda Chamberlain
Stephanie Charles
Jacob Cogan
max Cohen
Amanda hole
Suzanne Davis
Patricia Driscoll
Laura Durant
Ian savage Elliot
stepney Ellis
jeremy hotel
Katherine Fleming
ansley gates
jason gordon
Riley rates
Lola brillo
Jennifer Carrington knob
Jonathan payment
Elizabeth Hillenbrand
eco well
Kirsten Hubble
steve kessler
Sam kiernan
Maya Koenig's I'll ask
Jesse koski
Sailor creamer
Zhu Li Quan
Samuel lo Russo
Megan Leary
Margo leader handler
Allison levy
bedrock orenstein
Chad and Erin
Eden marks
David matherly
Rachel my soul
Daniel Modell
James Merritt
Calvin net
Michael matter
Antonio you manage
Victoria north
Caitlin O'Connor
or inhale
chalene ham panini
brittney banxxx Helene
Esther park
royal palace key
call tomorrow
Eric went on up
LSP Randall
a little rubber
Jenny riser
Casey Richardson
Rafael
Sarah showing up
bengali Rosado Romero
matthew Shapiro
Kyle Shepherd
jacob siegal
mary c slow
William Spiller
sir
benjamin sticks
Hilary Susskind
david alan thompson
Karen Tobias
Chelsea towns
Stacy almond
Nicole varallo
Lisa Messalonskee
Nora Villanueva
and NSF
if there are any more abdallah's left in
you let's give a big round to everyone
I'm happy to introduce Dean Andrew
sunshine director of the postback
pre-med program
I once saw a short animated film which
soldier comes to on a battlefield here's
the groans of an injured comrade and
undertakes to carry him to safety
cresting a hill the soldier sees below
him hundreds more lying wounded despair
wall but overwhelms the soldier he can't
possibly save them all finally he
decides that if he can save just the man
on his back it will be enough for now
and he presses on this remarkable film
was made by the next speaker max Cohen
after graduating from Vassar in 2005 max
worked as an EMT here in New York his
film there so God is a meditation on his
work as well told stories often do the
film tells a somewhat inconclusive tale
but there is a sequel in light of the
experiences that inspire the film max
decided to complete postback studies at
Columbia and apply to medical school max
has a deep understanding of the human
condition so I can't wait to hear his
account of life is post back please
welcome max Cohen
c2000
Thank You Tina lunch time for that very
very kind introduction and thank you
everybody for just giving me a few
minutes to talk to you on this really
really happy day I'm congratulations
everybody because we all did so much
stuff today over the past couple of
weeks I've talked to some of you about
sort of to describe your experiences as
post backs and almost everybody said
something first and occasionally only
about the difficulty and usually though
they said it in sort of cruder language
at night and it's true it was really
hard at times brutally so we all know it
inside and out almost everyone here is
fresh from the mod of the biology and
final exam yesterday and Q unlucky
people had their organic chemistry
finals yesterday too if point wasn't
clear before it is now but one day out
the difficulty of the program is already
sort of fading from my mind and I
studied a lot and I don't remember each
hour and the tests were at times hard
mention but they've also started to
merge together in my memory I remember
instead the moments when I experienced a
deep intellectual awe from the things
that we were taught professor beauty
who's been lecturing on physics since
1963 taught us that one out of every 100
dots in the static on an old television
is the result of micro
when filming across space since the Big
Bang I escaped a lab horse one day to a
room upstairs where graduate students
had created a small metal chamber that
was surrounded by lasers that contained
inside of the coldest cleanest place in
the entire universe and I worked for
many years as an artist and I never saw
anything as beautiful as the enzyme that
produces the energy of all multicellular
life twitching and spinning and a grainy
black-and-white video it's been a
privilege to spend two years just
skimming the surface of the sciences and
I'm in complete awe of the feats of the
countless women and men who created the
bodies of knowledge that have become
biology chemistry physics and
mathematics embracing this sense of the
law is one of the reasons that I've
enjoyed the last two years we all begin
this process knowing that it is in many
ways simply a Time Trial for medical
schools and with that mind we've all
felt that panic urged nor grades and the
median and the mean and the standard
deviations and the highest mode reach
test each quiz each homework assignment
succumbing to our fears would have
reduced these two years to an MCAT
preparatory course and I will not have
survived two years in mcat prep I may
not have survived a few months of it but
doctors Munich and mouths
many others did not see their territory
to our main they didn't just give us the
m10 we're a talented in driven bunch and
we can handle that on our own that's not
why they're here professor Beauty gave
me physics in all of its beauty stunning
complexity and eccentricity he was my
favorite we all had a teacher who moved
us and I'm grateful to him and to all
the professors who have made this an
intellectual experience and not merely
an exercise in just jumping through
hoops now I'm not denying us our moment
where we get to say columbia into our
families and to our mentors into our
peers that we have all gone through hell
to earn a place among the professional
healers we all gave up things to be here
and stopped our previous lives in order
to take the first tentative steps into
this new one but life itself never
stopped while we were here and I just
wanted to take a moment to acknowledge
that there is a shadow hanging over
today Morgan ash was one of us and she
died this year of leukemia I'm left
regretting that I didn't have the
opportunity to get to know her but many
people didn't and they all feel her
absence strongly we all made true
friends during these two years and in
the larger sense became a part of the
community a community that isn't whole
without her in our time here people we
knew passed away others were born and
our loved ones had their own triumphs
and setbacks what happened while we
thought that we were just preparing for
it I'm glad that we did not just rush
through this program
or simply wish it were over because
we're not careful we'll rush all the way
to the end and if there were moments
where we felt our hearts hardened where
the competition consumed even briefly
the desire to become healing to become
healers and ease suffering I hope that
we all resist it and can continue to
resist obscuring our humanity we are
only at very beginning of a long and
difficult academic road that will be the
most challenging due to its ability to
create a false distance between us and
the people who we would careful I
recently attended a luncheon on where he
talked about how much medical schools
love post bats which is a huge shift
from a few decades ago when there was
just a handful of non-traditional
students and if you took a few years off
a radically change direction it was seen
as a libel and now we are the it kids
why first and most obviously to me we
are all some mean curve killing machines
and on that note I think that it's
important that I apologize on our behalf
to all of the unfortunate undergraduates
Columbia University
who had to compete with the people in
this program and Thank You Columbia for
taking on this ragtag bunch of
overachievers and turning us all into
the strong applicants that we had become
but they have always been academically
talented people in medicine so what else
what else about house packs in
particular holds promise for the future
of this professional medical schools are
under a lot of pressure to humanize
their curriculum to produce physicians
receive people suffering beneath the
disease and they see our promise in our
experiences we aren't simply cutthroat
pre-meds we are people with lives and
commitments like the patients that we
would care for Michael v Bianco is one
of my friends in this program he had a
successful career in the software world
before deciding to join this one his
wife amanda was nine months pregnant
with their first child right before our
visits fun Mike told me that he was down
on his knees next to her belly begging
his child to please wait
please
very very gracefully Amelia postponed
her birth until a few days after that
test michael is new family were plunge
into the world of infant care with an
almost endless array of doctors and
checkups and nutrition considerations in
daycare the entire experience of having
a child all while studying magnetic
fields and molecular orbitals with the
rest of us he would tell stories during
our very frequent study breaks about the
good and the bad doctors and how clear
the differences were between them his
opportunity to live through all of this
from the patient's side before taking up
a stethoscope himself is invaluable mike
is a smart and thoughtful person and my
cougar dr. Amelia has given him the
chance to become a great one now I don't
have any children or any other way but
the point isn't that we are all like
Mike rather it's that we've all done
things that broaden our perspectives we
are business consultants and artists
chefs and opera singers nonprofit
do-gooders and corporate raiders
philosophers construction workers
theatre directors recent college
graduates and gay rights advocates all
of us have lived outside the fast lane
of this professional and can bring that
outside knowledge to the practice of
medicine and we can do our part in
helping this nation and the world
embrace the promises of humane care
dignity in our eclectic lives and now
certified accomplishments we will soon
have the power to ease suffering for all
people rich and forth insured and not
American and otherwise we can do this
work without eyes and hearts open until
illnesses never again the result of
inequality and indifference now let's
stop I've said a lot and if you remember
only one thank you everything that I've
said today it should be this wash your
hands unimaginable numbers that people
die in US hospitals each year because
well intentioned medical professionals
like the ones that we would become have
not yet embraced washing their hands
regularly simplest thing you can do to
help others
I'll leave you now with a line from
Dante's Divine Comedy not the famous
inscription on the gates of hell abandon
all hope ye who enter here number
instead it's the last line of the
inferno and then we came out to see once
more the Stars resolutions everyone
max thank you so much for that wonderful
wonderful speech with Max I want to
really acknowledge the family and
friends who are with us today and who
have perhaps like Amelia made sacrifices
over the last few years in support of
all of your education and perhaps we'll
have to continue to do so so thank
still I'd like to close our ceremony
today by speaking offering a few words
of praise and encouragement directly to
the students who are with us here today
because they've completed the columbia
university post baccalaureate pre
medical program this has been an
exciting and eventful year in the
program the PMA has had an amazing year
of programming in leadership and i also
want to acknowledge them for their great
service to the school
as happy as I am to celebrate with you
today like Max I know that the year has
been beside its challenges and
unfortunately also its tragedies you
know that I'm thinking also of Morgan
ash who wrote to me last August that the
prospect of returning to her posts
tagged studies was quote the light at
the end of my tunnel I'm so sorry that
she was not able to return to us and I
would ask all of our graduates in your
future work as healthcare professionals
to work in her spirit and on her behalf
but let me close with a few encouraging
words I want to honor the extraordinary
sense of dedication and purpose that
have brought you to this moment you have
toiled sacrificed and probably even
sweated perhaps as recently as last
night in response to a moment's
inspiration a moment that revealed to
you a vocation for healthcare you did
not allow that moment of insight to
remain an idle fancy or a plan for some
day later on you got to work and today
is the result of that you are now one
step closer to joining the medical
fraternity Voltaire wrote that quote men
and I add women who are occupied in the
restoration of health to other men by
the joint exertion of skill and humanity
are above all the great of the earth
they even partake of divinity since to
preserve and renewed is almost as Noble
as to create you have chosen a difficult
path and you have chosen it at a
difficult time at a true turning point
for medical care in
United States but the rewards for your
choice will be enormous and diverse I
know that this is not the end of the
educational role for you but rather the
beginning what I wish for all of you is
that the pride and sense of
accomplishment that you feel today will
buoy you up through the challenges that
lie ahead many of you came into this
program thinking can I really do this
can I have a career in health care today
you can tell yourself I can I will never
let that faith in yourself waiver our
faith in you certainly never will this
may be graduation but we will always be
here for you for advice for assistance
and for fellowship we will also be
calling upon you to mentor the
generations that will follow you please
stay in touch with us and allow us to
continue to cheer you on and support you
in your ascent to even greater
achievement congratulations once more to
you all
and my exams the over I invite you to
join us in the back of the Rotunda for
some refreshments thank you so much for
joining us today
you